[Music]
what is going on there so what is going
on there what is going on there citizens
of the reject nation greg here today so
with comic-con 2022 taking place and a
lot of people have been doing these
marvel announcement videos what to
expect i see it all over social media i
put out a post on our community page and
my personal twitter at the gregg goblet
you can follow me asking people what
they are hoping for gets announced now
honestly i'm tampering my expectations
simply because with it being marvel
knowing d23 is coming up in like a month
and a half they're probably gonna want
to reserve their biggest mic drop
announcements in-house with the mouse
house you know and i know we as fans can
be in dubiously anticipatory of what's
to be revealed and sometimes our own
personal desires leave us disappointed
although i am always okay with being
proven wrong i'm engaged trust me i get
it so what i wanted to do today was go
through the responses you loyal citizens
put down ever since i discovered that
word citizens i've been abusing it and
i'll give my two cents per mention to
let you know whether i think that's
actually going to happen or whether i
don't believe that's going to happen so
let's see what i get right or what i get
wrong come this saturday before we do
that leave a like or a dislike if you
already assumed the whole context of the
video based off the title and secondly
really quick in case you missed our
major announcement we partnered up with
heavy spoilers and screen crush to bring
you a one-stop nerd shop called zero
edition where we got some extremely high
quality merch it's a great way to
support the channel and show your love
of being a citizen of the reject nation
got some stranger things inspired shirts
as well we got more shorts more variety
in development as we were working with
our artists and right now we got a
limited run one meets one to become one
shirt or as pink be three
two three eight zero said on my
instagram stranger game squid things
thank you for that it's better than
squitter games all right guys let's get
into it
[Music]
okay so the top comment here says f4
cast that's fantastic four for sure
by the way i think it'd be a great idea
for you three to do like a prediction
video maybe you could even make a small
competition between you i'm just gonna
stop you right here look well first
things first koi is actually a comic con
doing several panels one isn't hall h
for keanu reeves and john brought the
vid diesel into my home and i tested
positive for the diesel still got it
right now hoping we're all clear by the
time saturday rolls around to cover all
the comic-con goodies but i'm gonna get
this out of the way in terms of
fantastic four
i wouldn't get my hopes up about it i
know that's upsetting to some people for
me to say that and don't get me wrong i
love to be wrong in instances like this
i just feel like they're probably going
to keep stuff more focused on stuff
they've already announced back with some
smaller announcements maybe a little bit
of exclusive footage and a trailer or
two but i really do believe the f4 cast
will be reserved for d23 and honestly i
actually think it might be cool if they
wait for d23 because that's when they
first announced the director who's no
longer the director but that's when they
revealed the logo this seems like it'd
be more fitting kind of like a full
circle thing next up mcgoof
i know i nailed that don't correct me
because it's correct i'm hoping to see a
black panther 2 teaser trailer deadpool
3 update and fantastic forecast i don't
mind if i don't get anything else but i
want these three without fail i
full-heartedly am expecting a black
panther 2 trailer i'd be shocked if we
don't get it it's the next movie set to
come out i know they're doing like a
little bit of reshoots right now it's
been like a forever shoot but they got
to have something ready now right they
gotta have something i imagine like this
is their event trailer though and a
deadpool 3 update
ooh oh that's a good one hmm
i think yeah
yeah they've already talked quite a bit
about this movie enough gets reported on
in the trades like he confirmed to be
rated r they got writers director
not confirmed sort of confirmed sean
levy so while i do really believe
they're going to preserve their biggest
stuff for d23 they got to have something
really special though to really hype us
up to make their return to comic-con
worthwhile more than just like black
panther 2. so yeah i'm saying yes to
deadpool 3. i think there's going gonna
be some deadpool 3 stuff i comic-con
next up is roger i heard the mutants
x-men film will be announced too so
definitely this isn't fantastic for
a lot of fantastic four okay with
mutants
i'm a little back and forth i think
they'll touch on it i think they're
going to touch on the fact that there
are mutants here now because of that
miss marvel ending reveal and you know
speaking of full circle with d23 the
first time feige mentioned we didn't
even talk about mutants was at the last
time they were at comic-con so i do
think they'll speak on it where i where
i don't think that what they're gonna do
is give an x-men movie announcement they
might give like a mutant character
announcement or maybe that rumored
mutants movie but i don't think we're
gonna get an x-men announcement that's
just what my instincts are telling me
but man i would love to be wrong on that
i need a new name i know said dr doom
announcement yeah that's not happening
no way no way in fact i'm hoping they
can keep doctor doom to such secrecy
manage to somehow never get that leaked
and that we never find out until we see
him in a post-credits scene but no
there's there's no i see a chief of
comments right here actually that are
saying doctor no it's not happening
doctor dude's not gonna get announced
ryun
sake again nailed it absolutely nailed
it deadpool three fantastic four another
one x-men reboot of course blade finally
a release date of course i expect
captain america for i feel like people
are sleeping on captain america four
yeah i think they'll definitely bring
captain america four up it's kind of
lacking in hype and they need to hype
that up but blade
yes i'm gonna say yes because that was
one of their major reveals from the last
time they were at comic con and and i
think they would want to follow up on
that i think they are in pre-production
right now that would make sense like
just gearing up ready to shoot so i do
think they'll bring something regarding
blade i did hear the rumor about
anthony star homelander possibly playing
the character dracula as the villain i
don't believe that although that would
be cool but maybe meet the cast at comic
con you know scrolling through this i i
just see a lot about fantastic four it's
making me want to take backstage
but instead it's staying in the vid
prove me wrong comic con powerful cat 72
gaming says avengers 5 or some kind of
movie that ties together characters from
the disney plush shows
if they do announce another avengers
movie or something that ties together
the characters like young avengers or
hell even thunderbolts or an avengers 5
i really think they're going to reserve
that for d23 thunderbolts maybe at
comic-con maybe thunderbolts but in
terms of you know the hero avengers
young avengers or avengers 5 highly
doubt that's going to be mentioned here
at comic-con it's got to be reserved for
d23 if they're going to announce it next
up is kalis riza la ha
again nailed it knocked it out of the
park don't correct me what i want to see
seriously is updates to quantum mania
guardians of the galaxy three and
possibly the fantastic forecast my god i
i i feel like i'm gonna really bite some
dust here you guys are making me doubt
myself but i just i just don't believe
it's gonna be announced i'd love for you
to be honest don't play fantastic what's
gonna get it i'm willing to eat my shoes
now this i honestly think we'll see more
details ant-man quantum mania i believe
they're in post-production right now
possibly on reshoots most likely but i i
do doubt we'll get footage although you
know a lot of times it's just about
bringing the cast out and you know the
director introducing them so be cool to
meet the new cassie lang they won't
explain what happened to the other
actress but it would be great to bring
out jonathan majors to talk a little bit
more about king maybe some like you know
footage reveals a little bit or or like
some photo reveals but you know marvel
they're they're backed up in the vfx
department right now i don't know if
you've ever heard anything about this
but apparently it's kind of a [ __ ] show
hence why i doubt they'd show us
anything from the film they tend to
reserve their trailers or footage like
two or three months before the movie
comes out now in terms of guardians 3
they just rap filming they probably need
to do some additional reshoots although
this can be a cool opportunity to bring
will poulter out on stage it was
revealed that he's playing adam warlock
not at some grand events it would be
cool to bring him out there james gunn
can vehemently defend chris brett the
way he does i like chris brett maybe
they'll tell us who chukwudi uh uh ujji
i think how you say saying the guy from
peacemaker that hasn't been confirmed
who is playing yet i highly doubt that
if high evolutionary is in this movie
that they're going to be like we got the
high evolutionary although that would be
a banger but so i do expect some
guardians 3 stuff but what i'm really
expecting is a trailer for i am groot
because that show comes out in just a
few weeks and maybe some footage or a
teaser trailer for the guardian's
holiday special and just while i'm on
the subject she-hulk trailer i expect a
she-hulk trailer as well really placing
my bets on the ones that everyone's
really wanting yup yeah the vibe i'm
getting is a fantastic four is not
announced there'll be some people
feeling let down that's the main demand
it's the main demand it's making me
doubt but i'm gonna stay strong swayam
daredevil continuation not a reboot well
it's already been reported on so i i
think the reboot though is actually
still a continuation of sorts i imagine
it's gonna be more like a soft reboot
what would be great is if they do bring
the daredevil show to comic-con that
they bring the whole cast out but i feel
like they're probably gonna make mention
of devil what i imagine they'll do is
redirect focus back on to ekko will we
get an echo trailer i doubt it but
they'll probably talk about it dion says
i'm either hoping for a scarlet witch
movie announcement or a new superman
movie with henry cavill announcement did
a video about that yesterday starting to
have my doubts though because i hear
he's filming witcher 3 in london right
now so maybe he doesn't have time but in
terms of solo scarlet witch uh very very
unlikely just a few months ago they
tried tricking us into thinking that
she's dead she's not she's not dead i
don't have confirmed sources here but
come on she's not dead but same thing
with like how daredevil was brought up i
think instead of scarlet witch they're
gonna be probably talking about house of
harkness and give us details on that
next up walter lopez i like this one
i can't wait to hear the words morbius
the more fun stuff version i would love
that yeah come on sony marvel make it
happen don't be cowards let's see let's
get one more in here and one more um
cinema tv
i'm run burgundy deadpool 3 rogue hero
thor rise of valhalla x-men minnesota g2
captain america serpent society good
titles but yeah definitely no thor 5
news nope not gonna happen and i don't
think we're going to hear anything about
shanghai too at comic-con maybe d23 for
shanghai too but thor 5 we went here for
a while they'll be announced with the
new director they can reign in take some
up and coming indie director off the
street and being like you listen unless
you tone down that goddamn comedy so
yeah as i'm scrolling through this the
main ones i keep seeing are fantastic
four easily the most predominant one uh
something with mutants x-men i actually
feel like something like that is a
little more likely than fantastic four
simply due to the ending of miss marvel
blade is the thing a lot of people want
um details on you know it's kind of a
toss up here i just think
don't expect too much but expect the big
one to really be d23 and whatever we get
just learn to appreciate it but yeah
guys this was fun i appreciate you guys
being here and uh couldn't contribute
into the narrative of the video uh so
subscribe click that bell leave a like
and hey you know what we do
brandon benzie thank you for becoming a
sexy reject you get a traditional first
shout out b
stands for bitchin r stands for rad
sandwich a stands for awesome tacular
buy it on blu-ray d
stands for
drunkalicious cause yamil woozy oh
stands for
auto octavius because you're a genius
and n
stands for you cannot say that word
you you are not allowed to say that word
let me look at your profile pic
i can confirm you're not allowed to say
that word stop it
you know what word
appreciate you being here buddy
hope you enjoyed your first shout out
and i was quick on that one and we will
talk to you guys soon